well one thing that's been amazing is to
meet all of the team behind the scenes
if we just turned up with a van and some
guitars and they said ok now you set
yourself up in halftime and you know it
would be dreadful we have all returned
here 50 people that work for us that's
not including probably a couple hundred
local stage hands 500 fill team members
that come together to push the stage
together it's just as fascinating to see
all the people on headsets and people
who practice to push the stage on and
people who built the lights everyone on
the pitch has got their own story in
their own journey of how they got there
and what they're doing this year is in
daylight so that gives a whole different
set of potential things you can do it's
certainly a big consideration a little
bit before Magic Hour there you've still
got you know so many great elements to
work with we know everything we do is
being seen entrances exits what also
means though is that we're gonna fill
the field with color choreography Ricky
and the team have done an incredible job
of really imagining what that moment
could be like in copla we always try to
give off shows dynamics make it big and
then bring it back and I make it big
again and just try to mix it up I think
the fact that this daytime is really
exciting so it's a whole different type
of production in a way it's liberating
sometimes the power of music is that it
can say something that you can't really
express with words somehow we love
interacting with people and singing
along with people and feeling the world
connect and I think this is one of the
days in the year when the world connects
yeah there's a game going on between
teams who really want to win but it's a
celebration of the sport in general and
it brings such amazing disparate parts
of the country and even the world
together around one moment
you